[Music]
everyone having their staff holiday
parties at work you doing that yet yeah
yeah yeah I have to say we had ours last
week and I see these people every day
but seeing them at that party that's a
lot of fun yeah yeah the holiday party
was a real great time a lot of fun hey
what did you say like that for well what
about the fight okay yes
there was a fight at the party that's
true things got a little out of hand
but I thought I handled it very well yes
very
[Music]
[Music]
man what a great party anyhow it's been
a great year Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas all yeah yeah Christmas the
year Santa gets laid okay
hey Dwayne yeah nice to see you Dwayne
ho ho ladies sit on my lap and I'll give
you a present
I'll take care of it all right come on
Dwayne that's a little out of line
yeah so this if you can't do that to
Andy and he's one of my friends call it
a Brian this time I'm really gonna kick
your ass
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
they've come back you okay Annie I took
care of them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yep I think I handled it pretty well
look that is not what happened and you
know you are the one that was stinking
drunk Andy I don't think I was stinking
drunk I really don't you're not this is
the year the host gets laid here you go
done and I got you a present present
what is it my father's approval
no it's a sweater then I don't want it
[Laughter]
in the corner I think you got too much
to drink
I'm gonna call you cap Oh had too much
to drink
let me call you an ambulance
[Music]
[Laughter]
: and I'm sorry this is for your own
good
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I prepared it yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you fired you are fired
I think you're the one that's fired
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's stop remembering things
I have English hiding away after because
we're out of cake